supongamos que este cuadrado completo
representa un entero y podemos ver que
parte de él está coloreado de azul lo
que vamos a hacer en este vídeo será
tratar de representar la parte que está
sombreada en azul como una fracción
como un decimal
y como un porcentaje pausa en el vídeo y
traten de hacerlo
bueno primero vamos a pensar esto como
una fracción el entero está dividido en
uno dos tres cuatro cinco seis siete
ocho nueve diez secciones iguales y seis
de ellas están sombreadas de modo que el
azul representa a seis décimos del total
o simplemente podemos decir seis décimos
y lo podemos reescribir si dividimos el
numerador y el denominador entre dos
esto es lo mismo que tres sobre cinco
ahora vamos a representar esto como un
número decimal que decimal será pausa en
el vídeo y traten de resolverlo
bueno para seis décimas literalmente
podemos ir al valor posicional esta es
la posición de las unidades tenemos un
punto decimal y luego tenemos la
posición de las décimas y como tenemos
seis décimas simplemente lo ponemos aquí
estamos poniendo el 6 en la posición de
las décimas para representar seis
décimas y ahora como escribimos el
porcentaje porcentaje significa por
ciento así que una manera de pensar en
esto es decir 6 sobre 10 es lo mismo que
que es sobre 100 si multiplicamos el
numerador y el denominador por 10 esto
será lo mismo que 60 sobre 100 otra
forma de pensar en esto es 60 y en lugar
de decir sobre 100 decimos por ciento
esto es igual a 60 por ciento hagamos
otro ejemplo una vez más tenemos este
cuadrado que representa un entero traten
de representar la parte sombreada en
azul como una fracción pausa del vídeo
bueno pueden ver que esta es una
cuadrícula de 10 x 10 así que tenemos
100 secciones iguales cada una de estas
secciones representa un centésimo
cuántos centésimas azules tenemos en
este renglón tenemos 10 20 30 40 y luego
1-2-3-4 de modo que esto es 44 sobre 144
centésimos y en realidad podemos
representar esto de otras formas podemos
dividir el numerador y el denominador
entre 4 y en este caso obtendremos 11
sobre 25 que es otra manera de
representar esta misma fracción y ahora
como lo escribimos como un decimal bueno
para 44 centésimas podemos decir que
tenemos la posición de las unidades
y de la misma manera literalmente
decimos que tenemos 44 centésimas esta
es otra manera de representar 44
centésimas cuatro décimas y cuatro
centésimas es igual a 44 centésimas y si
queremos escribirlo como porcentaje
bueno este es 44 sobre 100 o 44
centésimas pero incluso aquí me gusta
verlo como 44% o 44% así que esto va a
ser 44 % terminamos